okay guys i want to try something out
here a lot of you guys suggested that i
check out batman urban legends so i want
to try this first issue see how you guys
respond to it but batman urban legends
is a really cool concept
dc comics is publishing a couple of
these right you got batman legends of
the dark knight which is actually just
kind of a relaunch of the old
legends of the dark knight comics that
kind of came out after crisis on
infinite earth which basically explained
what bruce wayne was doing like in the
first year that he became batman kind of
the smaller scale stuff urban legends is
actually designed to kind of expand on
the gotham mythos right that you have
the main batman story that's being told
in the batman comics you've got the
stories being told in detective comics
this is designed to kind of flesh out
all the other stuff that bruce wayne is
doing besides those particular things
which is a cool concept because it's
kind of hard to believe that the world's
greatest detective is only ever handling
one case at a time and so it's kind of
interesting to see how all this stuff
ties in right so
what you initially end up getting here
is kind of a team up between
red hood and batman i don't really mean
a team up in the traditional sense
they're both hunting for the same thing
and they actually both end up coming to
blows with each other or at least seem
to
at a future point in time but this
actually just kind of focuses initially
on jason todd right on red hood as he's
kind of talking about how
fear is the tool of batman the fear is
something that batman uses in order to
get the upper hand
on the various villains who were out
there but the biggest difference between
the red hood
and bruce wayne is the red hood does
kind of rely on fear but he relies on
more of a direct fear that at the end of
the day the various villains like
penguin or two-face or those guys
kind of rely on fear with batman a
little bit but not so much because they
know he's only willing to go so far with
jason todd they know he'll kill him the
biggest issue with this
is that for jason todd to operate in the
city of gotham and this goes all the way
back to rebirth he can't really
kill people instead he uses rubber
bullets but the fear of being shot
with people believing the bullets real
is enough to motivate them to actually
do the right thing right to give him the
information that he needs and so what we
end up finding out here is there is a
kind of drug
that's been circulating around gotham
city this only really been here for a
couple of weeks
and the drug itself is destroying the
section of gotham that we call the
bowery right just one little
part of gotham city itself similar to
like crime alley different places like
that
but while he does track down one of
these guys who seems to have some kind
of involvement with it basically a drug
dealer he asked him like where do you
get this from and that's when we end up
finding out the nature of tear drops as
they're basically called and this is
kind of an interesting thing
because from what he tells us on the
surface it actually kind of seems
awesome right that it basically gives
people a sense of euphoria
and extremely pleasant hallucinations
right that basically it makes things
great it makes you feel good and it
makes you see great things the problem
is that people who
get addicted to it uh can actually get
trapped in that particular state right
they can get trapped in that kind of
euphoria that feel good feeling they end
up walking out in front of cars or they
end up drowning or they end up harming
themselves
all the while hallucinating this
incredible experience
and so while it does bring a great kind
of relief to people's lives
especially those who are probably
suffering with all kinds of mental
health issues the reality is it puts
themselves and other people in danger
and that's the desire to get it off the
street that's the desire to basically
get rid of it and that's when you kind
of have this bit of a situation
where jason is heading towards the
location of where these drugs are
supposedly being sold out of and that he
comes across a couple cops who are
possibly responding to gunshots and that
one of the cops talks about how he had
responded to a scene like that and there
were some kids down by the wharf who
were actually being taught how to shoot
guns
by members of a gang before they were
initiated and it's kind of crazy
because one of the guys makes this
response and talking about how kids
should just be allowed to be kids
they're being raised around all that
violence and all that conflict and stuff
like that
and jason has a bit of a flashback to
when he was being raised by bruce wayne
to when he was basically a little kid
who was kind of brought in
and then turned into the second robin
and that's kind of the funny thing here
is
jason's upbringing is not that different
from kids who are being taught how to
shoot guns
down by the wharf of course batman is
not teaching jason todd how to shoot
guns but he is teaching jason todd
violence he's teaching him conflict he's
teaching him how to harm other people
the difference between those kids who
are learning how to shoot guns
and jason todd as jason todd was being
taught how to do this for the purpose of
protecting other people
those kids are being taught how to do it
for the purpose of harming other people
but at the end of the day they're not
really just living kids lives now for
jason it was
always that way that was one of the
things that went on right that he was
kind of he was raised
his uh his mom had basically died of a
drug overdose but it was one of these
things where like his life was rough
like literally if you go with the old
school origin like when he first
appeared
he was discovered by batman because he
was boosting cars
he was boosting wheels off the batmobile
right so it's one of those those crazy
things because
in this instance when he's talking to
alfred and alfred's like you should be
practicing your your bat-shaped knives
you know throwing those you know
you're supposed to be doing this stuff
you know he gets kind of irritated
because he's like i've been doing it for
a week and he's like i just want to be a
kid i just want to have fun and
ultimately he's like i mean batman will
take you out when when he thinks you're
ready and so as jason todd goes into
the armory he ends up opening a door and
finding that it's filled with guns
right it's filled with with like
shotguns and automatic rifles and
handguns and the whole nine yards and
it's one of these things where batman's
like you're not supposed to be in here
and jason todd asked the most logical
question
why do you have this room i thought you
hated guns and that's kind of the funny
thing
is because batman does hate guns right
he's absolutely against guns and the
argument he makes here is i need them
for forensics work you've never seen me
use a gun you will never really see me
use a gun except for the times when
batman has used a gun but i need to
understand how these things work i need
to be prodigious with them because if i
understand how effective
a person can be in shooting this gun if
they're somebody like deathstroke then i
can i can basically contour my defense
of guns
around that which makes sense right
because i mean how effective could you
possibly be
if you're not very good at defending
yourself against the use of a gun facing
off against somebody who has a gun
right i mean you're going to be totally
screwed and so because of that he's kind
of like we are never ever going to use
guns right guns are a coward's weapon
and we will not be cowards and so he's
like it's time for you to basically
learn to start training
on how to use your batarangs and that
right there the way the
the kind of look that jason todd is
given that right there really seems to
indicate the beginnings of his
philosophy that batman was a half
measure that you could use a gun and put
criminals down for the count but batman
doesn't right they capture them they
hand them over to the cops the cops put
him in a judicial system the batman
knows won't be able to hold them
they get out and the cycle repeats
itself but regardless of the situation
one of these guys is kind of on a
rooftop right a person who is basically
using cheers
is standing on a rooftop and in turn is
getting ready to jump off which he
successfully does now of course batman
saves him but this is how the drug works
that this kid's kind of like oh dad this
has been the greatest day ever you know
and
let's do the roller coaster again and
jumps off right he's like here we go
you know and then in turn batman saves
him and so on but it's batman's going
through and analyzing this stuff these
tear drops you know how they impact
people how they affect people how the
chemical substance works that in his
mind it looks exactly like something
that jonathan crane the scarecrow would
use
the problem with this is that if you
guys remember the video that we did on
infinite frontier that during the a day
event right we talked about that in
joker yesterday the the event whereby
arkham asylum was basically attacked and
like 500 people died scarecrow was one
of them and so a scarecrow is not there
or at least
believed to be dead if he actually is
dead then how's he making this and
that's when batman entertains the
possibility maybe he's not
actually dead right maybe he's just kind
of underground but at that point they
can't really rely on that batman just
kind of has to focus on the idea of
getting down to where all this stuff is
coming from now
switching over to jason todd there's an
all too familiar situation that goes on
here when he finally locates the
building the dealer's not actually there
but when he gets to the apartment where
the dealer's supposed to be he ends up
finding that the the woman in there
has essentially overdosed and that her
kid is there watching it happen right
like he's just sitting there watching
his mom as she's essentially od'd
trying to get her to wake up that was
kind of a crazy thing because when that
goes down
jason's like no no it's okay she's
asleep she's asleep and tries to calm
this kid down as best he can
because he's been down that road before
he's been down this path and he's seen
that play out he also sees a couple
you know packets of the cheer drug out
there and he's like okay so this is
obviously what's going on he actually
ends up getting a hold of barbara gordon
and then says like i need you to trace a
phone number and then i need you to also
call 9-1-1 and get them here for this
kid's mom and then in turn
uh it's just kind of like we got to
figure out what to do with this kid
right like we have to figure out what's
going to happen
with this young man now this kind of
jumps into a little bit of a flashback
again
when it was essentially the revelation
that jason todd had returned and
presumably during the events of under
the red hood right when jason todd
basically came back to gotham city and
was then killing criminals in order to
one
move himself up the ranks of the
criminal empire by instilling fear in
that way to kind of solidify i'm not
batman i'm not a half measure i'm a full
measure and i will kill you
and the fact that batman became aware of
that right batman was aware that jason
todd was going through the city of
gotham and killing criminals and saying
he can't be allowed to kill people right
like
batman has to be the one that stops him
batman has to be the one that brings it
into
him which kind of brought in the the
sort of conflict with these guys now
for a lot of you guys out there who are
batman fans you guys already know
pretty much all this stuff but that's
one thing to know because urban legends
is a new title being launched
a lot of this is new to people right so
it's new to them even if it's not new to
you and so it's supposed to be kind of
written that way right designed that way
to kind of expand and enhance
on the existing mythos of of jason and
batman and why the two of them are so at
odds
most likely because the question anybody
would ask is if they're both hunting
after the same drug and they both know
who the other is
why are they not working together and
that's where that answer comes from
one of the cool things that goes on here
is jason actually takes this kid
and says okay like i need to keep an eye
on this kid but i also need to track
down this this drug dealer so here's
what you're gonna do kid you're gonna
chill here right you're gonna stay right
here you're gonna put this super mask on
and it's gonna keep you safe and if
anything happens if anybody shows up
here or you feel like you're in danger
if something scary happens
then just say oracle i need help of
course this mask having the ability to
tap into oracle the other funny thing
about this this kid's absolutely
adorable the other funny thing about
this is that when jason says like you
know what's what's your superhero name
going to be the kid's like what's your
name
he's like mine's red hood he's like okay
then i'll be the blue hood right so like
the kid kind of latches on to him
immediately right and i wouldn't say
sees him as like a very very good friend
but season is a kind of protector
and that's huge for jason todd because
jason's one of these guys where he's
kind of been isolated and alone for so
much of his life that at the end of the
day having a kid that kind of looks up
to him
and sees him as a sort of protector is a
cool thing it doesn't necessarily soften
the character
but it does give us insight into jason
todd in a way that we don't normally do
now that's what's kind of ironic about
it is because he comes across what's
basically the factory where tear drops
are essentially being being created but
as he gets in there he kind of starts
making this statement right you know
that if this was a previous point in
time
you know this kid's dad this kid tyler
you know his dad is just some kind of
hired goon that's in over his head i
would have put him down a long time ago
but i don't need batman on my back i
would say
that's not entirely true that jason todd
genuinely cares about this kid that's
sure i mean he probably doesn't really
need batman on his back making his life
a little rougher but i think more so
than that
this kid's already lost one parent it's
possible that jason todd can pull the
other parent back from the brink
because he doesn't really know why this
guy's caught up in it right it could be
one of these things where he was forced
into it that he got into it now he's too
deep and he can't get out
and all he's looking for is a lifeline
somebody who can get him out get him
into maybe some kind of witness
protection and him and his son can leave
and go to a different place instead what
happens
is that once jason todd gets up to the
sky that he basically ends up firing you
know a rubber bullet at him right kind
of incapacitating this guy and then in
turn he picks up his gun so the guy
can't use it and as he's talking to him
this guy is like look man like i found
your son
i found i found your kid you know your
wife is odd she's going to the hospital
something's got to be done here you got
to take care of your kid and the
response of this guy is
i don't care about that kid he was a
pain in my backside i don't care about
his
about his mom she could live or die as
far as i'm concerned i just care about
making this money and i just care about
getting these drugs around and the the
display of such
callousness on behalf of this guy is
enough that it sends jason todd over the
edge and he's like
no so he kind of pulls this pulls the
gun out right the gun with the rubber
bullets but the intention of just kind
of intimidating
and threatening this guy but when he
does when he goes to shoot him with
these rubber bullets
it's the real gun and he actually guns
this guy down in the city of gotham
so basically he killed tyler's death so
not only did he kill the dad of this kid
now he's gonna have batman breathing
down his neck i don't know about you
guys
but i am hyped for this for the for the
next part of this so with that being
said guys thank you all for watching god
i love jason todd he's such a great
character let me know what you think
down in the comments and i will catch
you all later
peace